j'ai déménagé bienvenue à la natif notre
tour d'horizon des jantes et du monde
sportif avec le en post prod sur un mur
de briques derrière le quart-arrière des
browns de cleveland baker mayfield et
certain à 100% d'avoir vu un ovni pour
chrome os est en plein pour ce genre de
nouvelle que j'adore faire la notice
mais quand mes filles raconte dans son
tweet qu'il a vu une boule de lumière se
diriger vers le lac crevé au texas en
revenant de souper avec sa blonde
il écrit dans son tweet quelqu'un
d'autre le vu comment on s'entend voir
un ovni c'est aussi improbable que voir
les brand se rendre au super bowl
c'est drôle mais cette histoire de nice
arrive la même semaine que sortent les
nouvelles images de space jam duda qui a
vraiment des aliens qui s'apprêtent à
envahir la terre et qu'on va devoir les
repousser avec une équipe de sportifs
professionnels liés à l'ohio baker
mayfield lebron james puis max rombi le
match des étoiles de la nba ont eu lieu
le week end dernier
[Applaudissements]
on a découvert la solution pour ceux qui
trouvent que le match des étoiles
c'est plat c'est le rock band 1 sport
russe qui combine la lutte olympique et
le basculement
on aimerait quand même se voir les
vedettes de la nba en combinaison ajusté
surtout james hold et peut-être que six
ans williamson est en train de faire la
prise de l'ours à steph curie et ne
réussirez pas aussi facilement ses tirs
de trois points d'une milieu de faire
c'est plutôt cocasse port ni pourront au
moins se déroule dans la balance au
rouge vous l'avions pas dire et brighton
deschambault a remporté le tournoi de
bay hill en exécutant une stratégie que
lui seul pouvait réussir au sixième trou
en forme de fer à cheval
parce que pendant que tous les autres
pros du circuit envoyer leurs balles au
même endroit dans l'allée grâce à la
chambre haute sénat
non la voie au dessus du lac 370 verges
plus loin tout le monde qui dit que le
golf c'est pas du sport regarder le lui
a fait de brassens deschambault c'est
ton ami qui a passé un an à étudier
toutes les pistes de mario kart et
pendant que tu a évité si cette carapace
rouge lui il faut que les raccourcis
ils sont la moitié du circuit pierrick
toile arrivé pendant que se fait frapper
par une portière carapace rouge t'as
fait vécu notre nouveau segment conseils
de pros avec olivier paventi le mieux
c'est moi à tous ceux qui rêvent encore
de jouer au wac et sur un lac cet hiver
on est rendu en mars les glaces
s'amincissent et vous n'avez pas les
habilités sous-marine deux royaumes
fouille avant de se lancer dans le lac
gelé qui aurait quand même pu enlever
son drive tout comme gilles durmois la
glace dans le dos ça parle à personne
sinon cool et le vraiment l'ami vraiment
d'avoir seul vous savez que l'entraîneur
des gardiens du canadien a été remerciée
entre la deuxième et la troisième
période la semaine dernière quand j'ai
dit stéphane wade pendant le deuxième
entracte c'est comme vous demandez
d'aimer et de partager la natif aux deux
tiers de la vidéo
merci d'ailleurs marc comment carey
price après ça de voir son entraîneur
personnel est remercié c'est plus que
lui prodigue grand chose
mikaël kingsbury est redevenu champion
du monde quelques mois après s'être
fracturé deux vertèbres
quand domine autant ton sport parfois il
faut un nouveau défi ça va être
suite sur une jambe un recul en intro à
skis c'est pour nous merci d'avoir été
là à la semaine prochaine continue et
demi le natif
ça va me permettre d'éviter de ferme cet
appartement comme j'ai perdu l'autre
au bas à regarder tout ça